It is publicly known that you and Hillary
Clinton are friends already for decades.
Friendships in the political world are rare.
What makes it that your friendship has survived?
I have known Hillary for almost 30 years and
I hope that when this conference takes place,
she has been elected president.
We share common values, political values,
but also I think that these are deeply rooted
in our own personal experiences.
We have defended these values against
all sorts of people who have used whatever
means that they could.
Many of them underhanded, in order to try
and destroy reputations. To attack people personally.
To engage in what we have called the politics of personal destruction,
but for political advantage and gain.
It is not only a bond of friendship,
but rooted, I think, in our common devotion
to advancing democracy in the country.
It sounds like a cliché but there it is.
We are a year apart in age, we grew up five
miles from each other.
We know very much who we are.
So, I think that there is a rootedness as
well in our commitment to engagement.
Does she realize the enormity of the responsibility
she will get when she is elected president?
I think if anybody understands the responsibility
of the presidency, it would be Hillary Clinton,
having served in the White House with her
husband and having been Secretary of State
with another president: Barack Obama.
There are very few people in American history
who have had that sort of background who have
risen to the presidency.
She would be a rare person.
Not only as the first woman but simply as
a person to assume that office.
Thank you, Sidney.
I am much looking forward seeing you on the
12th of November in Amsterdam.